With this lesson, we begin the second major unit of the course on software
architecture. Which is you recall, is the highest level of expression to
a design problem. In actual practice, software architecture and
industry usually amounts to the preparation of a slide for
display that contains some boxes and arrows depicting the major components of
a system, and how they're connected together. We want to take a more
principled look at what this essential aspect of software design is all about.
Here is such a diagram. The boxes depict major components of the system, and
the arrows indicate some form of dependency among the boxes. It might be
the flow of control, it might be the flow of data. The point being is that the,
there's no actual semantics to the diagram that is universally accepted.